Bethenny Frankel's daughter Bryn used to
make appearances on her Bravo shows but
she reveals why six-year-old Bryn is no
longer seen on reality TV I think it's
great that my daughters on the show I
really do the days of me putting people
on the show that didn't sign up for this
are over I've chosen this and I find it
to be very stressful and I find it to
definitely be interesting and a
therapeutic process but definitely work
I do feel like it is it is work it takes
a weight from running my businesses and
it's definitely a job and it's you know
it's a rose that has petals and thorns
so I don't think it's really a place for
a child when my daughter was a baby she
didn't really even know what's going on
but what are you bring a microphone on a
16 I just think it's mic her up yeah the
show is real the show is dramatic
everyone says that the best season ever
which is so I mean yay that's so awesome
um but it's hard I mean I am in the
middle of a lot of it and it's uh it
could be intense
we could come back for another season I
honestly I don't know I I you know when
I came back it is exciting to come back
because it had been a different show
that I left that I felt that I didn't
want to be part of and then I came back
and I was really proud to be back and
proud to say that I was a housewife and
this season is so great uh it has its
drawbacks you know I have so many
different businesses and I do my
daughter and I do a personal life and so
it's just it's a decision it's not me
just saying Oh be coy there are days
when I say I don't know is it worth it
how long am I going to do this I mean
I'm really glad I came back